Luces, máquinas tragaperras,
apuestas, póker, blackjack, es casi seguro que
cuando escuchamos estor términos nuestra
mente se desplace automáticamente hasta
el Strip de Las Vegas,
la ciudad de los excesos,
la ciudad que muchos consideran como la
capital del juego, ¿verdad, amigos? Pues
¡error! Porque la verdadera capital
mundial del juego no es Las Vegas sino
Macao.
Macao es una ciudad autónoma situada
en el sur de China,
muy cerca de Hong Kong. De hecho, están
tan cerca que la forma más habitual de
llegar a Macao es yendo
en unos ferries que van a toda velocidad, que conectan
estas dos ciudades en poco más de una hora.
Precisamente, es así como se fui a
Macao hace unos meses desde Hong Kong.
Si hubiera sabido que iba a hacer éste
vídeo hoy, probablemente habría hecho mejores.
Bien, cuando llegas a Macao te
encuentras con una ciudad bastante curiosa.
Por un lado es un pedacito de Portugal
dentro del caótico y vibrante sudeste
asiático; por otro, es un lugar donde es
fácil encontrar rascacielos y
llamativas construcciones modernas. La
perspectiva de la ciudad, por ejemplo,
está dominada por un enorme
rascacielos con cristales de colores que
tienen la forma de la flor de loto: el
Casino Grand Lisboa.
Y sobre todo, es una ciudad desordenada, un tanto
destartalada y llena de callejuelas.
Macao fue la última colonia europea
en Asia continental, y lo fue
prácticamente hasta antes de ayer.
Durante siglos fue parte de Portugal y a
finales de 1999 se integró en China. Lo
hizo como una región administrativa
especial donde rige el modelo de "un
país dos sistemas", el mismo que tiene
Hong Kong.
Estas dos ciudades, a pesar de ser partes
de China, mantienen, aunque con alguna limitación
limitación, sus propias leyes, aduanas
tribunales, monedad e instituciones
políticas. En la práctica funcionan
como países diferentes. En esta región,
incluso, el portugués es lengua oficial.
Ahora bien, Macao más que una ciudad
es una especie de parque temático del
juego, que cada año recibe a más
de 30 millones de turistas.
Sí, tal como lo escucháis, este
minúsculo trozo de tierra es uno de los
lugares más visitados del mundo.
¿la razón? Es el único lugar de China
donde se permite el juego.
Y en parte gracias a ello desde que se
separó de Portugal y hasta 2014
esta ciudad-región vivió uno de los
procesos de crecimiento económico más
rápido de la historia. En poco más de
diez años su PIB se multiplicó por
más de 10, pasando de 5 mil millones a
más de 55.000 millones de dólares.
En este vertiginoso proceso hay un momento
clave, el año 2002, cuando el gobierno
autónomo liberalizó la industria del
juego. En este momento las grandes
multinacionales del sector se
abalanzaron sobre ella, transformándo
su identidad para siempre.
- "Y en la cultura asiática
el juego es aceptado como forma
entretenimiento y ese es un detonante
para el éxito que se ve aquí y en Singapur".
Hoy es conocida como Las
Vegas china, por su altísima
concentración de casinos, pero la verdad
este es un calificativo casi ridículo
porque Macao, amigos de VisualPolitik, es la capital mundial del
juego. Sus más de 40 casinos facturaron
el pasado año la escandalosa cifra de
29 mil millones de dólares, casi cinco
veces más que Las Vegas. ¿Y sabéis qué?
Alcanzando, atentos, la friolera de
45 mil millones de dólares, que es casi
tanto como lo que ingresa España con
todo el turismo extranjero ¡Es para
quedarse boquiabierto! Juego, luces,
tiendas de lujo,  más luces...  esa es cada
vez más la identidad esta ciudad.
Ya lo sabéis, a partir de ahora cada vez que penséis en una máquina tragaperras,
en una mesa de póker o de blackjack,
no penséis en Montecarlo ni en Las
Vegas, pensad en Macao. Tan sólo en los
últimos doce meses se han abierto tres
nuevos macrocasinos con inversiones
milmillonarias. A finales de 2015 se puso
marcha el Studio City, un complejo ambientado
en Hollywood y para cuya inauguración
se grabó el cortometraje más caro de
la historia con un presupuesto de 70
millones de dólares. Fue dirigido nada
menos que por Martin Scorsese y sus
protagonistas fueron: Robert de Niro,
Leonardo DiCaprio y Brad Pitt.
Esto es una inauguración y lo demás son
tonterías.
Un poco más cerca, en agosto de 2016 abrió sus puertas el
Wynn Palace, un coloso de lujo con más
de 1.700 habitaciones que le ha
costado a sus promotores
nada menos que 4 mil 200 millones de
dólares.
El más reciente de todos, el último en abrir, ha sido The Parisian,  la
nueva joya del imperio de Las Vegas Sands,
la empresa que quiso construir
EuroVegas en Madrid
¿os acordáis? En este caso el complejo es
casi una ciudad. Tiene tres mil
habitaciones, un parque de agua e incluso
su propia Torre Eiffel.
Y las aperturas continúan, y el
siguiente será, prestad atención,
The 13,  el complejo de megalujo
más caro del mundo.
Cada una de sus habitaciones costará
entre 50.000 y 100.000 dólares por
noche.
No, no me he vuelto loco, sus huéspedes
tendrán incluso 30 Rolls Royce Phantom
a su disposición; aunque con esos
precios casi que se los podrían
hasta regalar. Junto a todas estas
incorporaciones, los casinos más
míticos de Macao son: el Galaxy,
el Grand Lisboa, El City of Dreams,  el
Venetian, el MGM y muchos más.
A este paso el Strip de Las Vegas nos va
resultar casi como una cosa de
principiantes.
En Macao más del 80% de los ingresos
gubernamentales proceden de los casinos,
y la cantidad de dinero que el gobierno
obtiene es tan elevada que cada año
tienen unos superávits  enormes. Aquí,
no saben lo que es el déficit público
y por supuesto como ya os podéis imaginar los impuestos son bajos. En este
caso la pregunta es clara ¿qué hace el
gobierno con todos esos superávit que
obtiene cada año? Pues bien una parte
los ahorra, otra la invierte en infraestructuras
y capital, y una tercera parte, atentos,
la reparte como dividendos a todos los
residentes de la ciudad ¡como lo escucháis!
Desde 2008 todos los habitantes de
esta ciudad reciben una parte de los
beneficios que el gobierno obtiene de los
casinos.
Este año, por ejemplo, la cantidad ha
sido de más de 1.000 dólares por
ciudadanos. Es decir, una familia de
cuatro personas, por ejemplo, recibe cada
mes un cheque del gobierno por casi 400
euros. No está mal ¿verdad?
Y los beneficios para los ciudadanos no
terminan aquí.
Casi una cuarta parte los empleos
dependen de la industria de los casinos.
Bajos impuestos, trabajo y encima
dividendos.
Ahora bien, no todo es color de rosas.
La  inmensa mayoría de los
turistas de Macao, dos terceras partes,
proceden de la China continental, con lo
que la economía de esta región
autónoma está íntimamente ligada a la
del gigante asiático.
Por si fuese poco, Xi Jinping el Presidente de China, puso en marcha una guerra contra
la corrupción entre los funcionarios, en
2015, y es entonces cuando la economía
de la ciudad se vino abajo.
- "Algunos de estos jugadores importantes
son funcionarios del gobierno chino, a
quienes por ley les está prohibido
entrar a los casinos y mucho más jugar".
En tan sólo un año, los ingresos del
juego se desplomaron un 40 por ciento,
y la economía de la ciudad perdió más
del 20% de su PIB, casi tanto como
Grecia desde 2008 ¡en sólo un año!
Los funcionarios corruptos chinos habían
cogido afición a los casinos de esta
ciudad.
Aquí podían gastar el dinero con un
relativa libertad, pasar temporadas a cuerpo
de rey e incluso, con un poco de suerte,
blanquear parte de sus nuevas fortunas.
- "la economía depende de la industria
de casinos, que representa del 80% de los
ingresos del gobierno y ha tenido
dificultades para adaptarse a la
campaña contra la corrupción lanzada
por Pekín en 2014.
No es que todo el sector dependiese de ellos ni mucho
menos, pero entre la desaceleración
económica y los nuevos controles
establecidos por el gobierno chino muchos
de los VIPs que acudían a Macao han
dejado de hacerlo, al menos por una temporada.
Y claro, la mitad de la economía de
mercado depende directamente de los
casinos.
De todas formas, gracias a la gran
acumulación de capital per cápita,
al buen estado de las finanzas públicas
y a las ventajas de ser un 'cluster'
turístico tan importante, los efectos
socioeconómicos han sido limitados:
el gobierno mantiene un holgado
superávit, la tasa de paro es de apenas
el 1,8 por ciento y los ingresos de las
familias no sean resentido.  A diferencia
de Grecia, Macao había hecho los
deberes.
Eso sí, ahora tal y como dijo Xi Jinping en su última visita a la ciudad
toca diversificarse: y el gobierno ya ha
presentado un plan al respecto.
Macao apostará en las próximos años
por impulsar el turismo de familia, el de
salud
el sector financiero y el tecnológico.
- "Las autoridades esperan, así, reducir la exposición de la economía a una
actividad tan volátil como el juego,
especialmente ante los pronósticos del
fondo monetario internacional que
prevén una contracción de las finanzas
chinas de un 7 con 2 por ciento".
La actividad económica ya ha comenzado a
repuntar y si se cumplen los planes del
gobierno, en unos años Macao puede
llegar a convertirse en una especie de
Mónaco del siglo XXI.
El error de la ciudad fue apostar por
sólo un sector y no por facilitar la
creación de empresas y la atracción de
inversiones con independencia del sector
al que perteneciesen. Algo que de forma
bastante más grave también ha ocurrido
en Atlantic City, pero de eso
hablaremos otro día.
¿Qué os ha parecido el caso de Macao? Si querés que sigamos
hablando de Asia
no olvidéis darle a like a este vídeo  para hacérnoslo saber. Y si aún
no estás suscritos al canal, leñe
hacedlo ahora pulsando este botón y
recibiréis nuestros nuevos vídeos al
instante.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.
-"Los
encargados vigilar a los jefes de mesa,
los jefes de planta vigilan a los
encargados, los managers vigilan a los
jefes de planta,
el gerente del casino vigila a los managers, yo vigilo al gerente del casino
y el ojo de la cámara nos vigila a
todos nosotros.